En los últimos vídeos hemos trabajado bastante
con esta idea de exponentes negativos,
tanto que llegamos a la siguiente relación.
Dijimos que "a" elevado a la -"b",
esto lo podemos ver, esto es equivalente
a tomarnos a 1... a 1 y...
¡0h! Espera que feo 1...
a tomarnos a 1 y a este 1
dividirlo entre "a"
entre la misma base,
elevado ahora a una potencia positiva
y justo a esta igualdad llegamos
y con ésta hemos venido trabajando bastante
en los vídeos pasados.
No obstante aunque ya hemos trabajado mucho con esta idea y con esta relación,
me gustaría que quedara mucho más claro el concepto o la idea de lo que es un exponente negativo.
Así que para eso se me ocurre que hagamos un experimento con las potencias de 2
y a ver si así entiendes un poco mejor,
qué es lo que está pasando con un exponente negativo. Fíjate bien,
imagínate que yo tengo a 2 elevado al cubo...
2 elevado al cubo,
bueno, nosotros sabemos que esto es lo mismo que
2 por 2, por 2 lo cual es 8.
Ok, ¿y cuánto es 2 elevado al cuadrado?
Bueno, pues 2 elevado al cuadrado es
2 por 2 lo cual es 4.
Ok, y 2 elevado a la primera potencia
bueno, pues esto es 2...
esto es 2,
date cuenta que lo que estamos haciendo aquí es dividiendo entre 2,
de aquí... y déjame cambiar de color...
de aquí para acá, lo que hice fue dividir entre 2...
dividir entre 2 y de aquí para acá
lo que hice fue dividir también entre 2
Ok, vamos bastante bien,
ahora qué te parece si nosotros pensamos
en 2 elevado a la potencia 0,
bueno, pues esto va a ser igual
y nosotros siguiendo este mismo patrón,
tendremos que dividir el 2 entre 2...
2 entre 2 es 1 pero, además sabemos
que eso es completamente cierto.
Por definición 2 elevado a la  0 es 1,
y eso lo hemos dicho varias veces,
todo número elevado a la 0 es 1, excepto el 0.
Muy bien, pero además lo podemos ver de la siguiente manera.
Si dividimos el 2 entre 2,
llegamos a que 2 elevado a la primera potencia es 2,
2 elevado a la potencia 0 es 1.
Lo único que estoy haciendo
es manteniendo este patrón de dividir entre 2.
Ahora vamos un paso más abajo.
Qué te parece si ahora dividimos entre 2,
pues vamos a llegar
a que 2 elevado a la potencia siguiente, es decir,
-1, le voy a bajar 1 al exponente, esto va a ser igual a
1 dividido entre 2...1 dividido entre 2,
1/2
que es justo lo que ya sabíamos,
y lo podemos ver justo
con esta expresión que tenemos aquí.
2 elevado a la - 1 es 1 entre 2 elevado
a la primera potencia,
pero además acabamos de ver que esto también
es bastante consistente,
y no sólo eso,
date cuenta que 2 elevado a la - 1,
es 1/2 que es el recíproco o el inverso multiplicativo
de 2 elevado a la primera potencia,
que por cierto, es 2,
pues bueno, vamos a mantenernos haciendo esto.
Para esto déjame bajar un poco la pantalla...
vamos a bajar un poco la pantalla,
y ahora trabajemos con las últimas potencias
que se me ocurre trabajar con ellas de 2.
Vamos a hacer a 2 elevado a la - 2.
Bueno pues siguiendo este mismo patrón lo que tengo que hacer es dividir esta expresión de aquí entre 2.
Me voy a dividir otra vez esto entre 2
¿y qué voy a llegar?
a que esto es exactamente lo mismo
a 1/2 entre 2 que sabemos que es 1/4...
1/4...
y otra vez utilizando las leyes de los exponentes
tiene bastante sentido.
Fíjate bien, 2 elevado al cuadrado es 4
y si a esto mismo lo ponemos 1 entre 4,
voy a llegar a 2 elevado a la -2,
que por cierto, es el inverso multiplicativo de 4,
es el inverso multiplicativo de 4...
Muy bien, y ya para concluir podemos decir
que 2 elevado a la - 3
es exactamente lo mismo que 1/4
entre 2 lo cual es 1/8
y lo que estoy haciendo es dividir este número entre 2...
entre 2 siguiendo este mismo patrón,
y date cuenta que 2 elevado a la -3,
es el recíproco...
déjame cambiar de color...
es el recíproco de 2 elevado a la tercera potencia
es decir, de éste de aquí.
Es el inverso multiplicativo
y además 2 elevado a la -3 es lo mismo que
1 entre 2 elevado al cubo,
que es 8, pero ya está.
Aquí tienes otra manera de pensar
inversos multiplicativos recíprocos
pero, sobre todo las potencias negativas
tanto viéndolas como el recíproco de un número,
o también las podemos ver como 1 entre
la misma base elevada a la misma potencia,
solamente que positiva.